Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill, four-burner gas grill, on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $499. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies last, price invalid May 14th or May 27th. U.S. only exclusions apply.
Home Depot 的阵亡将士纪念日特惠让您的夏天即刻开启。是时候用下款烤炉（一款四燃烧器燃气烤炉，特价仅售 199 美元）开启夏日烧烤了。还有汉普顿湾西格罗夫七件套户外餐桌椅，仅售 499 美元，让您整个季节都能尽情款待亲友。在这个阵亡将士纪念日，来 Home Depot 享受低价保证。数量有限，价格有效期截至 5 月 14 日或 5 月 27 日。仅限美国，不适用于部分商品。
See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. Speaking of psychology is taking a winter break, so we're rerunning some of our favorite episodes from the past. In 2022, I talked to psychologist Carla Sharp about borderline personality disorder, including how this frequently misunderstood disorder is diagnosed and treated. We hope you enjoy this episode from the archives. Speaking of psychology, we'll be back with new episodes in January. Thank you for listening. Today we're going to talk about the most frequently diagnosed personality disorder that many of you may never have heard of. But if you have, you might not really understand what it is because even its name is somewhat enigmatic. Borderline personality disorder
详情请参见 Home Depot.com 上的价格匹配页面。说到心理学栏目正在进行寒假休息，因此我们正在重播过去的一些最爱单集。2022 年，我与心理学家卡拉·夏普（Carla Sharp）谈论了边缘型人格障碍，包括这种经常被误解的障碍是如何被诊断和治疗的。我们希望您喜欢这期来自档案的节目。说到心理学，我们将在 1 月携新节目回归。感谢您的收听。今天我们将讨论最常被诊断出的人格障碍，许多人可能从未听说过它。但如果你听说过，你可能并不真正理解它是什么，因为连它的名字都有点神秘。边缘型人格障碍
is a condition marked by intense emotions that are typically hostile, angry, or depressive in nature. People with BPD may have a history of impulsive behavior and chaotic relationships. Many fear being abandoned and may tend to see the world as purely black or white. Some engage in self-harm or suicidal ideation, and what may be the most challenging about this disorder is that many people with BPD are able to project an appearance of total normalcy. So what makes borderline personality disorder its own diagnosis? How does it affect people's trajectory in life? How is it different from other personality disorders? How might you tell if someone you know has it or if you yourself might have it? And if people with BPD are high functioning and appear quote unquote normal, how can the disorder be diagnosed and treated?
是一种以强烈情绪为特征的病症，这些情绪通常具有敌意、愤怒或抑郁的性质。患有 BPD 的人可能有冲动行为和混乱人许多人害怕被遗弃，并且往往将世界视为纯粹的非黑即白。有些人会进行自残或产生自杀意念，而这种障碍最具挑战性的地方可能在于，许多患有 BPD 的人能够展现出完全正常的表象。那么，是什么让边缘型人格障碍成为一种独立的诊断呢？它如何影响人们的生活轨迹？它与其他人格障碍有什么不同？你如何判断你认识的人是否患有此病，或者你自己是否可能患有此病？如果 BPD 患者功能良好并且表现得“正常”，那么这种障碍该如何诊断和治疗呢？
Is it really a discrete mental illness? And what makes BPD controversial among mental health researchers and practitioners? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Carla Sharp, Professor and Associate Dean for Faculty and Research at the University of Houston. She is also director of the University's Adolescent Diagnosis Assessment Prevention and Treatment Center and the Developmental Psychopathology Lab. She holds adjunct positions at the University of Texas, Baylor College of Medicine, University College London, and the University of the Free State in South Africa. Dr. Sharp has a long-standing interest in social cognition as a cause and correlate of psychiatric disorders
它真的是一种独立的精神疾病吗？是什么让 BPD 在精神健康研究人员和从业者中充满争议？欢迎收看《说到心理学》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我今天的嘉宾是休斯顿大学教授兼教师与研究副院长卡拉·夏普博士。她还是该大学的青少年诊断、评估、预防和治疗中心以及发展心理病理学实验室的主任。她在德克萨斯大学、贝勒医学院、伦敦大学学院和南非自由州大学担任兼职职务。夏普博士长期对作为精神障碍原因和相关因素的社会认知感兴趣，
across the lifespan with a special focus on youth. She has published over 300 peer-reviewed articles, numerous chapters, and eight books. A large proportion of her research uses borderline personality disorder and other personality pathology to study where social cognitive function goes awry. Thank you for joining me today, Dr. Sharp. Thank you so much, Kim. I'm so glad. to be here with you talking about this topic that's very close to my heart. Well, let's start by talking about personality disorders in general. How does psychology categorize and define personality and personality disorders? And how is this area of psychology evolving? Well, that is a very big question,
研究横跨整个生命周期，并特别关注青少年。她发表了 300 多篇同行评审文章、众多章节和八本书。她的很大一部分研究利用边缘型人格障碍和其他人格病理学来研究社会认知功能在何处出现偏差。非常感谢您今天能来，夏普博士。非常感谢你，金。我很高兴能和你一起在这里讨论这个我非常关心的话题。好吧，让我们先来谈谈一般的人格障碍。心理学是如何对人格和人格障碍进行分类和定义的？心理学的这一领域又是如何演变的？嗯，这是一个非常大的问题，
and I'm going to try and keep it succinct. The diagnosis of personality disorder is a disorder or a diagnosis in transition. For the last 20 to 30 years since the publication of the DSM 3, we have been ascribing to a system of diagnosing personality disorder that we call the categorical system. It is based on a medical model in the sense that we see disorder as something that a person has or does not have. You can think a little bit about pregnancy as an example. You can't be halfway pregnant. You're either pregnant or you're not pregnant. And in the same way in the categorical system of diagnosis, we view someone as having a personality disorder or they don't have a personality disorder. Now, this has been the way we've diagnosed personality disorder since the DSM3, which was published in the 1980s. However, over the
我将尽量简明扼要地回答。人格障碍的诊断是一个处于转型期的问题或诊断。在过去 20 到 30 年里，自《精神疾病诊断与统计手册第三版》（DSM-3）发表以来，我们一直沿用一种被称为分类系统的诊断系统。它基于一种医学模型，即我们将障碍视为一个人“有”或“没有”的东西。你可以把怀孕当作一个例子。你不可能怀着半个身孕。要么怀孕，要么没怀孕。同样，在分类诊断系统中，我们认为某人要么有人格障碍，要么没有人格障碍。自 20 世纪 80 年代出版的 DSM-3 以来，我们一直采用这种方式诊断人格障碍。然而，在过去的
last 20 to 30 years, we have discovered that this categorical system has some limitations to fully understanding and treating personality disorder. So one of the important data points in this regard is that when we take all of the personality disorder symptoms, and I should just explain first that there are in the categorical system, there are 10 personality disorder, 10 categories of personality disorder. And one of them is, for instance, BPD that you mentioned, borderline personality disorder. Another one is narcissistic personality disorder. A third one is antisocial personality disorder. So there's 10 of these personality disorders in the current system of diagnosing personality disorders. When you take all of the symptoms of those 10 personal disorder
20 到 30 年中，我们发现这种分类系统在全面理解和治疗人格障碍方面存在一些局限性。因此，这方面的一个重要数据点是，当我们把所有的人格障碍症状放在一起时——我应该先解释一下，在分类系统中，有 10 种人格障碍、10 种人格障碍类别。其中之一就是你提到的 BPD，即边缘型人格障碍。另一个是自恋型人格障碍。第三个是反社会型人格障碍。所以在当前的诊断系统中，有 10 种这样的人格障碍。当你把这 10 种人格障碍的所有症状
and you put them together into a big factor analysis, you would expect you will get to 10 factors pushed out by the factor analysis. This is how factor analysis work. If we want to understand a particular phenomenon, we put the signs and symptoms of that phenomena into a factor analysis and we get one dimension out that explains that phenomenon. In the case of personality disorder, we want to be able to see if they really exist in nature, like the DSM would suggest, we want to be able to see 10 personality disorders come out. out of a factor analysis. So we want to see the symptoms of BPD hang together to form borderline personality disorder. We want to see the symptoms of narcissistic personality disorder to hang
组合成一个大的因素分析时，你可能会期望通过因素分析得出 10 个因素。这就是因素分析的工作原理。如果我们想了解某种特定现象，我们把该现象的体征和症状放入因素分析中，就会得出一个解释该现象的维度。在人格障碍的情况下，如果我们想看看它们是否真的自然存在，就像 DSM 所暗示的那样，我们希望看到从因素分析中得出 10 种人格障碍。因此，我们希望看到 BPD 的症状聚合在一起形成边缘型人格障碍。我们希望看到自恋型人格障碍的症状聚合在一起形成自恋型人格障碍。反社会型、回避型、表演型，这 10 种人格障碍都是如此。当把所有这些症状放入因素分析时，实际情况是什么呢？它是一个维度的巨大混杂，这些类别中没有一个能非常清晰地分离出来。因此，这是这些类别并不像我们一直认为的那样在自然界中存在的首要且最重要的迹象之一。事实上，当你符合像 BPD 这样的诊断标准时，你可能同时也符合其他两到三种人格障碍的标准。当你符合 BPD 的标准时，你可能还符合——这让情况变得更加复杂——抑郁症、焦虑症和物质使用障碍的标准。
together to form narcissistic personality disorder. Same with antisocial, same with avoidance, same with histrionic, all of those 10 personality disorders. What happens in actual fact when you put all of those symptoms into a factor analysis, it's a big mishmash of dimensions and none of these categories come out very clearly. And so this has been one of the first and most important signs that these categories don't exist in nature as we have always thought they did. In fact, when you do meet criteria for something like BPD, you probably also meet criteria for two or three other personality disorders. When you do meet criteria for BPD, you probably also meet criteria, this makes a picture even more complex, for depression and anxiety and substance use disorder.
我们现在处于历史和领域的这样一个时刻：我们决定从这种人格障碍分类诊断系统转向我们所称的更多维度的系统。因此，当你打开《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》（DSM）时，第五版于 2013 年出版。当你打开 DSM 时，你会发现平行的两个系统来诊断人格障碍。在 DSM 的第二部分，你会发现旧的 10 个类别。BPD 会在那里，自恋会在那里，反社会等等。它们都会在那里。但当你翻到后面，你会在第三部分找到人格障碍的替代模型。这就是人格障碍的维度模型。这就是我们未来发展的方向。我可以多告诉你一点这意味着什么，以及为什么我们向这个维度发展是很重要的。
We are now at a point in our history, in the field, where we have decided to move away from this categorical system of personality disorder diagnosis to what we call a more dimensional system. And so when you open the diagnostic and statistical manual for mental disorders, the DSM, the fifth edition was published in 2013. When you open the DSM, you will actually find two parallel systems for diagnosing personality. disorder. In section two of the DSM, you will find the old 10 categories. BPD will be there, narcissism will be there, antisocial and so forth. They will all be there. But when you page forward, you will find in section three, the alternative model for personality disorder. And this is the dimensional model for personality disorder. And that is where we are moving towards in the future. And I can tell you a little bit more about what that means and why that is important.
但我先说到这里，看看你是否对刚开始提到的类别有什么后续问题。嗯，这非常复杂。对于试图做出诊断的临床医生来说，这肯定是一个挑战。我的意思是，如果它与这么多其他事情重叠，你怎么能真正说某人患有 BPD？或者是否存在一定数量的特征、某种公式，能说明这个人患有 BPD 或者是另一种障碍？嗯，目前，当我们使用 DSM 第二部分时——这也是大多数临床医生仍在使用的部分——
that we are moving towards this dimension. But I'll stop there for now and see if you have any follow-up questions about just the categories to start with. Well, it's very complex. And it's got to be a challenge then for clinicians who are trying to come up with a diagnosis. I mean, how could you actually say somebody has BPD if it overlaps with so many other things? Or there's a certain number of traits, a kind of formula that says this person has BPD or has a different disorder? Well, at the moment, at present, when we use Section 2 of the DSM, which is what most clinicians still use,
临床医生会觉得诊断某人患有 BPD 相对直接，因为有九个标准。所以，你知道，这些标准是情感不稳定，即情绪不稳定、愤怒、自杀倾向、空虚感、身份认同紊乱、遗弃恐惧、人际关系问题和冲动性。因此，当临床医生遇到某个人，而这个人告诉他们，你知道，他们不知道自己身上发生了什么，他们有很多关系方面的困难。他们服用SSRI（选择性5-羟色胺再摄取抑制剂）很长时间了，似乎没有什么用。他们尝试过各种疗法，似乎也没有用。他们仍然有很多关系困难。他们有自残行为。
clinicians find it relatively straightforward to diagnose someone with BPD in the sense that there are nine criteria. So, you know, those criteria are affective instability, so mood instability, anger, suicidality, emptiness, identity disturbance, abandonment fears, relationship problems, and impulsivity. And so when a clinician meets someone and the person tells them that, you know, they don't know what's going on with them, they have a lot of relationship difficulties. They've been on an SSRI for a long time, doesn't seem to be helping. They've tried all kinds of therapy. doesn't seem to be helping. They still have lots of relationship difficulties. They're self-harm.
他们有自杀倾向。临床医生就会开始认为这可能是人格障碍，因为患者对抑郁、焦虑、物质滥用的传统治疗方法没有反应。通常这告诉我们，在人格功能领域有额外的事情正在发生。因此，临床医生可以逐一核对这九个标准。如果这个人满足这九个边缘型标准中的五个或更多，那么这个人就被认为符合边缘型人格障碍的临床阈值标准。这完全没有问题。然后临床医生会像目前所做的那样，诊断 BPD，诊断抑郁症、焦虑症、通常交织在一起的物质使用障碍。如果他们探讨不同的人格障碍，
They're suicidal. The clinician will start thinking this may be personality disorder because the person is not responding to traditional treatment approaches for depression, anxiety, substance abuse. Usually that tells us that there's something extra going on in the personality functioning domain. And so the clinician can then go through those nine criteria. And if the person meets five, or more of those nine borderline criteria, then the person is deemed to be meeting criteria, clinical threshold for borderline personality disorder. And that's all fine. And the clinician will then simply do what they do currently, which is diagnose BPD, diagnose depression, anxiety, substance use disorder, which usually hang together. If they explore a different personality disorder,
一个人可能还会符合另一个人格障碍的标准。所有这些信息都进入了患者的病历中，临床医生的工作就是同时治疗所有这些共病的障碍。我认为这没问题。这就是我们过去 30 年来运作的方式，我们取得了中等的成功。一旦一个人被诊断出患有 BPD，他们通常会接受 BPD 的一线治疗之一，即辩证行为疗法（在美國最常见），或者他们会接受以心理化为基础的疗法（在欧洲更常见）。还有一些其他有循证依据的治疗方法，比如移情聚焦疗法、图式疗法。
a person may then meet criteria for another personality disorder as well. And all of that information goes into the person's chart and the clinician has the job to treat all of this co-occurring disorders at the same time. And I think that is okay. That's how we've been functioning for the last 30 years and we have moderate success with that. Once a person's been diagnosed with BPD, they usually get one of the frontline treatments for BPD which is either dialectical behavior therapy, which is most common in the US or they would get mentalization based therapy, which is more common in Europe. There are some other treatment approaches, too, that are evidence-based, like transference-focused therapy, schemer-focused therapy.
事实上，有很好的证据表明，老式的 CBT（认知行为疗法）实际上对 BPD 患者也很有帮助。所以我们有这样做的途径——没错，就是认知行为疗法。因此，这个系统有其行之有效的方法，但我们认为我们可以做得更好。我们认为，借助新的诊断系统，我们可以更准确地诊断更广泛的人格障碍。但我们也可以让它变得稍微没有那么复杂，不必面对需要各自手册化治疗的共病大杂烩。因此，该领域一直在寻找由所有人格病理学共享的共同因素、共同维度，以便我们能够简化这个迄今为止我所概述的非常复杂的
And actually, there's good evidence showing that good old CBT can actually be helpful for people with BPD as well. So there are ways in which we, that's right, cognitive behavioral therapy. So there are ways that this system has worked well enough, but, we think we can do better. We think with a new system of diagnosis, we can actually be more precise in diagnosing people with personality disorder more generally. But we can also just make it a little less complex than having this co-occurring mismatch of disorders that each require their own manualized treatment. So the field has been looking for common factors, common dimension, that is shared by all of the personality pathology so that we can simplify this very complex
过程。那么，在所有人格障碍中，BPD 的致残性有多大？我认为它是被诊断最多的人格障碍，这部分是因为 BPD 似乎捕捉到了所有人格障碍所共有的一些东西。我确实想谈谈我一直提到的、所有人格障碍所共有的这个维度。那么，该领域正在走向的、帮助我们更好地定义人格障碍的这种维度方法是什么？所以如果你——我将回到我刚才稍微介绍过的因素分析，
process that I've so far outlined. So how debilitating is BPD among the constellation of personality disorders? I think it is the most diagnosed personality disorder, and that is partly due to the fact that BPD appears to capture something that is common among. all of the personality disorders. And I do want to talk a little bit about this dimension that I've been mentioning that is shared by all of the personality disorders. So what is this dimensional approach that the field is moving towards that helps us better define personality disorder? So if you, I'm going to go back to factor analysis, which I introduced a little bit earlier,
作为使障碍合法化的一种方式，对吧？如果你必须进行因素分析，实际上我将对人格障碍的所有症状进行因素分析。在最近的研究中，从该因素分析中得出的实际上是我们所说的“一般因素”，即人格功能的一般因素。现在，如果你们的听众过去听说过智商（IQ）是如何运作的，他们就会知道，当我们考虑智商时，我们会认为智商为 100 的人具有平均智商。我们会认为智商为 120 的人高于平均水平。而 140 的人则属于优秀，对吧？我们也会认为 70 左右的人智商较低。所以存在一个共同的维度，即智商的一般因素。现在，在这个智商一般因素的内部，
as a way of legitimizing disorders, right? If you have to, you have to factor analysis, which I'm going to actually do factor analyze all of the symptoms of personality disorder. What you do get out of that factor analysis in more recent studies is what we call a general factor, a general factor of personality functioning. Now, if your listeners have been hearing about how IQ works in the past, they will know that when we think about IQ, we think about a person with that IQ of 100 as having average IQ. And we think about a person as having an IQ of 120 as above average. And a person with 140 as superior, right? And we would also think about someone at 70 as someone who is lower in IQ. So there's a common dimension, a general factor of intelligence. Now, within that general factor
我们可以认为有些人非常擅长数学，但不太擅长语言，或者有些人处理速度非常快，但不擅长数学。因此，我们可以考虑人们在智商的具体方面有所不同的具体方式，即使他们的平均智商、一般智商可能处于某种水平。人格领域也朝着相同的方向发展，
of intelligence, we can think about people that are very good at math, but not so good at language, or people that are very fast at processing speed, but they're not so good at math. So we can think about specific ways in which people differ on specific aspects of intelligence, even though their average, their general IQ, can be at a certain level. The field of personality has moved in that same direction,
我们不再考虑这 10 个类别，而是开始考虑一般的人格功能，如果你愿意的话，可以称之为一种“人格商”，而不是智商。与其说是智商，不如说是人格商。当我们思考您的人格功能时，我们想要探讨的是：在人际交往的背景下，您管理自己的能力有多好？当您忙于与其他人互动时，您在解读他人的互动、揣摩他们的心思以及管理自己的表现方面有多好？所以这里的简写版本是
where we, rather than thinking about the 10 categories, we are now thinking about a general personality functioning, a sort of personality quotient, if you will, rather than an intelligence quotient. Rather than IQ, we can think about personality quotient. And what we want to talk about when we think about your personality functioning is how good are you at managing yourself in the context of interpersonal interactions? How good are you at reading other people's interactions, reading their minds, and managing yourself when you are busy interacting with other people. So the shorthand version of this is
适应性或适应不良的自我和人际功能。这似乎就是人格功能的一般因素。我们在依恋关系背景下管理自我的能力有多好？我们在人际关系背景下管理自我的能力有多好？如果你擅长这一点，那么你就拥有高人格商。你在自己的人格功能方面做得相当不错。如果你不擅长这一点，并且很容易情绪失调，很容易产生防御心理，开始在人际交往中进行补偿，对自己的想法和别人的想法感到困惑，开始将自己
adaptive or maladaptive self and interpersonal functioning. And that appears to be the general factor of personality functioning. How good are we at managing the self in the context of our attachment relationships? How good are we at managing the self in the context of interpersonal relationships? If you're good at that, then you have a high personality quotient. You're doing pretty good on your personality functioning. If you're poor at that and you get dysregulated really easily, you get defensive really easily, you start compensating in the interpersonal interactions, you get confused about what's in your mind and what's in the mind of other people, you start projecting what's in
心里的想法投射到别人身上，开始指责别人而不承认自己身上发生了什么，而不是为自己对关系破裂所负的责任承担责任，当我们处于那个领域时，我们就是在说你拥有低人格商。你在人格功能领域做得不太好。而且似乎这个维度是所有人格障碍的共同因素，无论你患有 BPD、自恋型人格还是反社会型人格。所有在人格功能方面存在问题的人都在挣扎，
your mind onto other people, you start blaming people and not owning what's going on for you rather than taking responsibility for your contribution to the breakdown in a relationship, when we are in that domain, we are saying you've got low personality quotient. You're not doing so well in the personality functioning domain. And it seems that this dimension is the common factor for all personality disorder, whether you've got BPD or narcissistic personality or antisocial. All people who have problems in personality functioning struggle. to manage themselves, to regulate their self in the context of interpersonal interactions.
无法在人际交往的背景下管理自己、调节自我。所以回到你的问题，你知道，BPD 的致残性有多大？BPD 是致残的，但我认为我们现在处于这样一个时代：我们希望抛弃 BPD 本身的这种概念，只需将人格功能的一般因素视为适应不良的自我和人际功能，并且我们所有人都在这个连续体上。我有状态好的日子，情绪调节得很好；我也有状态不好的日子，情绪调节得没那么好。我们所有人都能对此产生共鸣。问题是，在人际交往背景下调节自己的能力方面，我大多数日子里能达到平均水平以上吗？如果我做不到，那么我就需要寻求帮助，因为我可能在关系领域存在问题，需要特定种类的治疗
So to get back to your question, you know, how debilitating is BPD? BPD is debilitating, but I think we're at a time where we want to move away from the concept of BPD per se. And just think about the general factor of personality functioning as maladaptive self and interpersonal functioning and that we all lie on a continuum there. I have good personality days where I'm well regulated and I have bad personality days where I'm not so well regulated. We all can identify with that. The question is, do I get over, you know, average on most days in terms of my ability to regulate myself in the context of interpersonal interactions? And if I do, then I need to seek help because then I probably have problems in the relational domain that needs a specific kind of treatment.
才能好转。对，对。所以如果它干扰了你的日常生活，那么你就应该寻求一些治疗。我正想说，如果你在工作中很难与人和睦相处，如果你在个人生活中很难与人和睦相处，
in order for it to get better. Right, right. So if it's interfering with your everyday life, then you should seek some treatment. I was going to just say, if you're struggling at work to get on with people, and if you're struggling in your personal life to get on with people,
那么你知道你可能是一个在人格功能上有挣扎的人，你需要向专家或理解人格的人寻求帮助。你曾说这里离水面只有几步之遥。我们只是还没找到那些台阶罢了。我们省了多少钱？够了。
then you know you're probably someone that struggles with personality functioning and you need to seek help from an expert or people that understand personality. You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough.
足够让我们迷失自我了。或者你也可以预订希尔顿的房间。欢迎来到你的海景房。距离水面仅几步之遥。希尔顿促销活动正在进行中。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿 App 上预订，最高可省 20%，获得你期望的住宿体验。当你想要省钱，而不是惊吓。
Enough to get lost. Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water. The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises.
住哪里，至关重要。希尔顿，每一次入住。所以我先问一个非常基础的问题，即在 BPD 的背景下，“边缘”（borderline）这个术语的含义是什么？边界究竟是在什么之间？这是一个非常好的问题。这也是一个非常有趣的问题，因为最初当斯普策（Spitzer）创造这个术语时，他实际上试图阐明精神病（psychosis）和神经症（neurosis）之间的边界。这是，你知道的，60 年前，60 多年前的事了。在那个时候，我们认为精神疾病
It matters where you stay. Hilton for the stay. So I wanted to ask a really basic question, which is what is the meaning of the term borderline in the context of BPD. What's the border between? That's a really good question. And it is a very interesting question as well, because originally when the term was coined by Spitzer, he actually tried to articulate the border between psychosis and neurosis. And this was, you know, 60 years ago, more than 60 years ago. And at that time, we thought about mental illness,
要么是精神病性的，要么是神经症性的。神经症性障碍是，你知道的，抑郁症、焦虑症，其中并没有发生与现实的真正的脱节。精神病性障碍则是发生了与现实脱节的情况，就像精神分裂症一样。使人格病理学如此有趣的是，它实际上两者都不是，它比神经症稍微多一点，但比精神病稍微少一点。因此，患有 BPD 或人格病理学的人，他们不会经历与现实的真正脱节。但有时他们看起来有点像精神病，因为他们似乎非常固定和僵化
either as psychotic or neurotic. The neurotic disorders are, you know, the depression, anxiety disorders where there's not a real break with reality occurring. The psychotic disorders are the ones where there is a break with reality occurring like in schizophrenia. What makes personality pathology so interesting is that it really is neither, it's a little bit more than neuroticism, but a little bit less than psychoticism. So people with BPD or personality pathology, they don't experience a true break with reality. But sometimes they appear a bit psychotic because they seem so fixed and rigid
地看待正在发生的事情。在没有任何充分证据的情况下，对于别人在如何看待他们这一点上，他们甚至可能给人一种有点妄想的感觉。因此，这让人觉得这看起来像精神病，但它实际上并不是精神病，
in their view on what's going on. They could almost come across as being a bit delusional in what they think someone else is thinking about them in the absence of any good evidence. And so that has made people think this looks like psychosis, but it isn't really psychosis. and it certainly doesn't respond to antipsychotics like schizophrenia with, but it's not as mild as neurosis where there is a good sort of reality testing
而且它当然不像精神分裂症那样对抗精神病药物有反应；但它又不像神经症那样温和，在神经症中有着良好的现实检验能力，并且可以很容易地与一个人讲道理。有时，对于患有 BPD 或人格障碍的人来说，要与他们讲道理是非常困难的，因为他们在现实观上变得非常、非常固定。我们在以心理化为基础的理论中，
and a person can be easily reasoned with. It's very difficult sometimes with a person with BPD or personality disorder to reason with them because they get very, very fixed in their view of reality. And we call that in mentalization-based theory. we call that psychic equivalence. What is in my mind is true. And to help they move away from this very fixed idea that what's actually in your mind is a representation of reality,
称之为“心理等同性”。我脑子里想的就是真的。为了帮助他们摆脱这种非常固定的想法——即你脑子里的东西实际上是对现实的一种表征，
it doesn't necessarily map onto reality perfectly. It's a representation of reality that we can test and explore and put to the test to see how true it actually is. So that was what Border originally meant. So one of the areas where you have done some groundbreaking work is around diagnosing BPD in younger people in adolescence. Can you talk about that? I mean, adolescence is a time of stormy emotions, moodiness, confusion. I mean, how could you diagnose a kid as having BPD when, you know, he or she is still going through all of this developmental turmoil? Oh, absolutely. So you're right. We, up until about 10, 15 years ago, even though it was allowed in the DSA to diagnose BPD in a young person and a person below 18 years of age, we really did it. Because there were these myths about personality and personality functioning in young people, one of the things that we thought was that personality wasn't stable until people reached the age of 18. And, you know, when you wake up with your 19th year after your 18th birthday, people thought, you know, suddenly.
它不一定与现实完美对应。这只是我们可以检验、探索并加以测试以了解其真实程度的现实表征。这就是“边缘”最初的意思。因此，你开展开创性工作的一个领域是围绕诊断年轻人（即青少年）的 BPD。你能谈谈这个吗？我的意思是，青春期是一个充满风暴般的情绪、多愁善感、困惑的时期。我的意思是，当一个孩子（你知道的，他或她）仍在经历所有这些发展动荡时，你怎么能诊断他或她患有 BPD 呢？哦，绝对是的。所以你是对的。我们，直到大约 10 到 15 年前，尽管在 DSM 中被允许在年轻人和 18 岁以下的人身上诊断 BPD，但我们确实很少这样做。因为当时存在关于年轻人的人格和人格功能的一些迷思，我们当时的看法之一是，在人们达到 18 岁之前，人格是不稳定的。并且，你知道，当你满 19 岁、过完 18 岁生日醒来时，人们会认为，突然之间
you had a stable personality and yesterday you didn't. Of course, that's not true. We now know from temperamental research in children that actually little babies coming to the world with very, quite stable patterns of approach and avoidance behavior. Some babies are smiley, open babies, and they like new experiences. And some babies are avoidance babies and they just, you know, need a little bit more from the environment to help them feel calm. And so those that are temperamental traits that become personality traits as they begin to interact with the environment. And so these stability coefficients turn out to be as stable in children, adolescents, as they are in adults. So the idea that personality isn't stable in adolescence was pretty much debunked
你就有了一个稳定的人格，而昨天你还没有。当然，这不是真的。我们现在从儿童的气质研究中了解到，事实上，小婴儿来到这个世界上时，就带着非常稳定的一套趋近和回避行为模式。有些婴儿是爱笑、开朗的婴儿，他们喜欢新的体验。有些婴儿则是回避型的婴儿，他们只是，你知道的，需要环境给予更多一点帮助，让他们感到平静。因此，这些都是气质量，当他们开始与环境互动时，气质量就变成了人格特质。事实证明，这些稳定性系数在儿童和青少年中与在成年人中一样稳定。因此，认为人格在青春期不稳定的观点在几年前就已经被彻底打破了。
a few years ago already. The other idea that people had was that, you know, there is this normative, increase in personality flavored disorder. All adolescents, like you said, are a bit more emotional, they do get more impulsive. They are a little bit more self-centered, all of them. And that is normative. So how do we know whether a 15-year-old who is impulsive and emotional and egocentric have narcissistic personality disorder or whether they have BPD? And so that was the other, one of the other myths that people had and made them reluctant to diagnose BPD in young people, they thought, well, they'll grow out of it. Turns out that a good proportion of young people who show that normative increase in borderline traits during adolescence do not grow out of it.
人们拥有的另一个观点是，你知道，存在这种规范性的、带有特质的人格障碍的增长。所有青少年，正如你所说，都更加情绪化，他们确实变得更加冲动。他们都有点以自我为中心。这是规范性的。那么我们怎么知道一个冲动、情绪化且以自我中心的 15 岁孩子是患有自恋型人格障碍还是患有 BPD 呢？所以这是另一个迷思，人们因此不愿意在年轻人身上诊断 BPD，他们认为，好吧，他们长大后就会自然好转的。事实证明，相当一部分在青春期表现出边缘型特质规范性增长的年轻人并没有长大后自然好转。
And so it still is an important clinical decision to make whether this young person, are they on a trajectory to stay high in terms of borderline traits through adolescence and never really go down again like their peers? Because what the normative increase eventually shows a normative decrease again in borderline traits by about 25 years of age, most young people normalize and they don't show this sort of upheaval in terms of emotion dysregulation that they showed when they were 15 and 16. But a proportion of young people get stuck.
因此，这个年轻人是否处于在整个青春期保持高水平边缘型特质、并且不像同龄人那样真正下降的轨迹上，这仍然是一个重要的临床决策。因为规范性增长最终会表现出边缘型特质的规范性下降，到大约 25 岁时，大多数年轻人会恢复正常，并且不会表现出他们在 15 岁和 16 岁时表现出的那种情绪失调的动荡。但有一部分年轻人卡住了。
And so the clinician's job becomes to be able to predict who's going to be stuck and who's not going to be stuck. When I see young people in our clinic, who's 15, who meet criteria for BPD, I usually look at some of the protective factors in order to decide, is this a young person who's going to be stuck or is this the young person who is going to show the normative decrease. And so I would say to a parent, you know, your child meets five criteria for BPD right now. but I don't think it's going to stay because I can see that the child is getting a lot of scaffolding at home. You're slowing down a lot around emotional content. You're patient with her. You stay with her. You validate her emotions.
因此，临床医生的工作就成了能够预测谁会被卡住，谁不会被卡住。当我在我们的诊所看到 15 岁、符合 BPD 标准的年轻人时，我通常会查看一些保护性因素，以便决定：这是一个会被卡住的年轻人，还是一个将表现出规范性下降的年轻人？因此，我会对父母说，你知道，你的孩子现在符合 BPD 的五个标准，但我认为不会一直这样，因为我能看到孩子在家得到了很多支持框架。你们在情绪内容周围放慢了脚步。你们对她很有耐心。你们陪伴着她。你们认可她的情绪。
You're here seeking help from us. That's a good sign. We need to make sure that she has a life, that she continues to do sports and cultural activity so that she continues to feel engaged. Here are all of the things that we can do to scaffold the personality consolidation. But sometimes I see a young person who doesn't have that protective factors. And then I would tell the parent, you know, I do think there is some risk here that she can get stuck and that she can't, she won't sort of get relief from these symptoms as she age out of adolescence.
你们来到这里向我们寻求帮助。这是一个好迹象。我们需要确保她拥有生活，她继续参加体育和文化活动，以便她继续感到投入。以下是我们为了巩固她的人格可以做出的所有事情。但有时我看到一个没有这种保护性因素的年轻人。然后我会告诉父母，你知道，我确实认为这里存在一些风险，即她可能会被卡住，并且随着她度过青春期，她将无法从这些症状中得到缓解。
But here's what I think we need to do in order to make sure that she shows the normative decrease that her peers, So I think that becomes the clinician's decision point, you know, is what other protective factors are in the environment to help a young person follow her peers down the normative trend versus get stuck and continue to have this elevation of borderline traits through through adolescence and young adulthood. So I want to talk a little bit more about parental involvement here. and I'm wondering about the theories around the causes of BPD. So is it, if you happen to be the child of, say, a parent who is borderline, might you learn those behaviors and begin to exhibit them yourself as a young person? Or is it the result of trauma, or do we not even know? You know, I think there is a relatively good evidence to suggest a 55% heritability for BPD
但这就是我认为我们需要做的事情，以确保她表现出与同龄人一样的规范性下降。所以我想这成了临床医生的决策点，你知道，环境中的其他保护性因素是什么，以帮助年轻人追随同龄人的规范趋势，而不是卡住并在整个青春期和青年期继续保持这种边缘型特质的升高。所以我还想多谈谈父母在这里的参与，我想知道关于 BPD 成因的理论。所以，如果恰好是一个有边缘型倾向的父母的孩子，你是否可能会学到这些行为并在年轻时自己表现出来？或者它是创伤的结果，还是我们甚至根本不知道？你知道，我认为有相对充分的证据表明 BPD 和整个人格障碍具有 55% 的遗传度。因此，这些冲动性、情绪失调的特质——你知道，大多数患有 BPD 的年轻人和成年人都被描述为具有敏感气质的人。从他们很小的时候起，他们就表现出我们常说的“薄皮”。你知道，他们的感情很容易受到伤害，很容易觉得被别人轻视。因此，我认为确实存在气质生物学成分。
and for personality disorder in general. So these traits of impulsivity, of emotion dysregulation, you know, most young people who, and people with BPD are described as people who have a sensitive temperament. From the time they were young, they evidenced what we always refer to as thin skin. You know, their feelings are hurt easily, and they feel slighted easily by others. And so I do think there is a temperamental biological component.
玛莎·林内汉（Marsha Linehan）的理论——玛莎·林内汉开发了辩证行为疗法，这是 BPD 的主要治疗方法之一——玛莎·林内汉的理论被称为 BPD 的生物心理社会理论。她承认 BPD 具有很强的生物学成分，我认为数据已经证实了这一点。但有大量的人带着敏感的气质来到这个世界，最终并没有患上 BPD。
Marsha Linehan's theory, Marsha Linehan developed dialectical behavior therapy, which is one of the main therapy approaches for BPD. And Marsha Linehan's theory is called a biopsychosocial theory for BPD. And she acknowledged that there's a strong biological component to BPD, which I think the data has borne out. But there are plenty of people who come into the world, with a sensitive temperament who don't turn out to have BPD.
这些人通常是拥有这样的照顾环境的人：父母不知怎么地找到了耐心和余力，去迎合那种气质，与之一半对一半地相遇。你知道，过去曾有一个时期，父母被指责为患有人格障碍的原因，我很高兴我们已经度过了那个时期。我有时在临床医生中仍然看到这种情况，无论我去哪里，我都试图推广这样一种观点：父母不应该为人格障碍的发展承担责任，因为抚养一个具有高度敏感气质的孩子是非常困难的。他们对父母的要求确实更高。而且，你知道，
And those are usually folks who have had a caregiving environment where the parents somehow found the patients and the reserve to meet that temperament halfway. You know, there used to be a time when parents were blamed for personality disorder and I'm so glad we passed that. I still see that sometimes among clinicians and wherever I go, I try to promote the idea that parents are not to blame for the development of personality disorder because it's very difficult to parent a child with a highly sensitive temperament. They do ask more of a parent. And, you know,
我非常清楚地记得，一位母亲曾经告诉我，她有一个患有 BPD 的年轻人，她说，你知道，当我让她把鞋子收起来时，她会觉得那是在否定她。因此，当父母抚养一个有着非常、非常薄的皮、有着非常、非常敏感气质的孩子时，他们必须付出更多努力去真正放慢脚步。如果你们的听众能带走我这些年学到的任何真理金块，那就是：放慢脚步。那么，你如何要求一个敏感气质的孩子把鞋子收起来呢？大多数父母，包括我，都会直接说把鞋子收起来。但如果你意识到你有一个敏感气质的孩子，那么你将不得不说，你知道，我看到你现在正忙着你的 iPad。
I remember so clearly one mother once told me she had a young person with BPD and she said, you know, when I asked her to put her shoes away, she would find that invalidating. And so a parent has to work so much harder when they have a child with very, very thin skin, with very, very sensitive temperament to really slow down. And that's if your audience can take away any nugget of truth that I've learned over the years, it's slowing down. So how do you ask a child with a sensitive temperament to put their shoes away? Most parents, including me, will just just say put your shoes away. But if you're aware that you have a child with sensitive temperament, then you are going to have to say, you know, I can see that you're busy with your iPad right now.
我们一会儿有客人要来。我能请你把鞋子收起来吗？所以你可以看到，这花了更长的时间，比“请把鞋子收起来”长了 100%。但当你和一个敏感气质的孩子打交道时，你将不得不放慢脚步。并且你必须在日程中留出时间来创建一个不会让年轻人感到被否定的环境。当然，也要有必要的平衡，你也不能有一个任何事情都可以发生的放任自流的环境。你作为父母必须付出非常大的努力，在“我认可你的立场可能来自哪里”与“作为父母我也有需求、我们的环境有需要遵循的需求和规则”之间取得正确的平衡。但“放慢脚步”是我给家里有敏感气质孩子的父母的主要建议。
We're going to have guests coming over in a few moments. Can I ask you that you put your shoes away? So you can see that took longer, 100% longer than can you please put your shoes away. But when you're dealing with a child with a sensitive temperament, you're going to have to slow down. and you're going to have to build into your schedule time to create an environment that doesn't feel invalidating to the young person. Of course, with the necessary balance as well, you can't have a laissez-faire environment either where anything goes. You'll have to just work really hard as a parent to get the balance right between I'm
你今天花时间在当下放慢脚步，将来就会成百倍地节省时间，因为你避免了住院治疗以及伴随患有 BPD 的年轻人而来的各种危机。这种方法对患有 BPD 的成年人也有效吗？
validating where you might be coming from, but I also have needs as a parent and our environment has needs and rules that need to be followed. But slowing down is the main advice that I have for parents with children with sensitive temperament. The time that you take to slow down in the moment today, you're going to save 100-fold over in years to come when you're avoiding inpatient treatment and all the kind of crises that go with a young person with BPD. Does that same approach work with an adult who has BPD?
我的意思是，假设你正在与一个具有许多这些特征的人交往？为了适应他们的反应方式，你必须以这种方式行事吗？绝对的，绝对的。所以我最经常使用的治疗方法被称为以心理化为基础的疗法。这种放慢脚步实际上就是我们所说的“心理化姿态”。心理化姿态是我们为了帮助另一个人而采取的姿态。让他们感到被理解或被验证。如果你使用 DBT（辩证行为疗法）的语言，你会说你让另一个人感到被验证。在 MBT（以心理化为基础的疗法）的语言中，我们说我们让一个人
I mean, let's say you're in a relationship with somebody who has a lot of these characteristics. Do you have to behave in that way in order to accommodate the way that they react? Absolutely, absolutely. So the therapy approach that I use most often is called mentalization-based therapy. And this slowing down is really what we call the mentalizing stance. And the mentalizing stance is the stance that we take in order to help another person. feel understood or validated. If you use DBT language, you would say you make another person feel validated. In MBT language, mentalization-based therapy language, we say we make a person
感到被理解。患有 BPD 的人有一种几乎是存在主义的被误解感。他们感到非常疏离，不仅与社会、与家庭成员疏离，也与他们自己疏离。他们在自己的身体里感觉不到像在家里一样的舒适。他们在自己的身体里感觉不舒服。这是一种非常、非常孤独的存在。因此，家庭成员和 BPD 治疗师能做的事情就是帮助他们感到被理解。只有当我们放慢脚步时，我们才能真正帮助人们感到被理解。当我们把我们的想法摆在桌面上并说，你知道，这对我来说是一个两难境地。
feel understood. People with BPD have almost existential feeling of being misunderstood. They feel very alienated, not only from society, from their family members, but also from themselves. they don't feel homey in their own bodies. They don't feel comfortable in their own bodies. And it's a very, very lonely existence. And so what family members can do and therapists for people with BPD is to help them feel understood. And we only help people feel understood when we slow down. And when we put our mind on the table and say, you know, this is a dilemma for me.
一方面，我觉得我想在这方面帮助你。另一方面，我觉得我不想干涉你正在忙的事情。这让我们处于什么境地？通过这样把你的想法摆在桌面上，通过解释而不是妄下结论或走捷径，你向你的沟通对象灌输了一种被理解的感觉。所以绝对的，金，你说得完全对，无论是为了我们生活中的儿童，还是为了成年人，也为了治疗师。我们放慢脚步。这是与 BPD 患者相处的唯一途径。
On the one hand, I feel I want to help you with this. On the other hand, I feel I don't want to interfere with what you're busy with. Where does that leave us? In putting your mind on the table like that, in explaining rather than jumping to conclusions or taking shortcuts, you instill in the recipient of your communication, a feeling of being understood. So absolutely, you're absolutely right, Kim, for both for children, but also for adults in our lives, also therapists. We slow down. It's the only way to go with people with BPD.
一方面，我觉得我想在这件事上帮你的忙。另一方面，我觉得我不想干涉你正忙的事情。我们该怎么办呢？通过这样坦诚相告，通过解释而不是妄下结论或走捷径，你会让沟通的对象产生一种被理解的感觉。所以绝对没错，Kim，你说得完全对，无论是对孩子，还是对我们生活中的成年人，甚至对治疗师都是如此。我们慢了下来。这是与边缘型人格障碍（BPD）患者相处的唯一方式。
Last big question. What are the next areas of critical research for BPD? We absolutely have to move the field to the dimensional system. So we have to get away from the categories. And I hope the next time I speak with you, I don't even talk about BPD anymore. and I talk about personality problems writ large or personality difficulties or personality challenges or maladaptive self and interpersonal functioning. Rather than talking about BPD, I think BPD has become so stigmatized. We have so many wrong ideas about BPD and people with BPD that and to understand that all of us have bad self and interpersonal days.
最后一个重大问题。边缘型人格障碍（BPD）接下来的关键研究领域是什么？我们绝对必须将该领域推进到维度系统。所以我们必须摆脱分类。我希望下次与你交谈时，我甚至不再谈论BPD，而是广泛谈论人格问题、人格困难、人格挑战或适应不良的自我和人际功能。与谈论BPD相比，我认为BPD已经变得如此污名化。我们对BPD和BPD患者有太多错误的想法，我们需要理解的是，我们所有人都有自我和人际关系糟糕的时候。
none of us can always be perfect in our management of interpersonal relationships. It's our biggest challenge every day. And yes, people with BPD or with personality disorder will have more occasions when they lose it with people, but we all can relate to that. And to put that on the same dimension and to acknowledge the continuum between typical and atypical personality functioning is where we need to go. So I think there's a lot of empirical research. support of these ideas, what we now need is the treatment research that shows that when we use
我们没有人能够在处理人际关系时总是完美的。这是我们每天面临的最大挑战。是的，BPD或人格障碍患者会有更多对他人失去控制的时候，但我们所有人都能对此产生共鸣。将其放在同一个维度上，并承认典型与非典型人格功能之间的连续性，正是我们需要前进的方向。因此，我认为有大量实证研究支持这些观点，我们现在需要的是治疗研究，它表明当我们使用
the dimension to identify people into our randomized control trials for personality pathology treatment, we have the same effect as when we categorize people into BPD and we enroll them into our treatment trials. So I think the next big step for us is to do randomized control trials with alternative model defined personality disorder and not the old categories. That's definitely the biggest new challenge for us. Well, Dr. Sharp, this has been really interesting. I appreciate you're taking the time to talk to me today and to explain this really complicated disorder. Really, thank you so much. Thank you. It was my pleasure. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.w.w. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher,
该维度将人员识别并纳入我们的人格病理治疗随机对照试验中时，我们能取得与将人员分类为BPD并将其纳入治疗试验时相同的效果。因此，我认为对我们来说下一个重大步骤是开展采用替代模型定义的人格障碍而非旧分类的随机对照试验。这绝对是我们面临的最大新挑战。好的，夏普博士，这次访谈非常有趣。感谢您今天抽出时间和我交谈，并解释这个非常复杂的障碍。真的非常感谢您。谢谢您。这是我的荣幸。您可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或通过 Apple、Stitcher
or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you heard, please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondy. Thank you for listening. The American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There's a new way to Sweet Green. Meat, wraps, handheld, hearty, and made for life on the moon. With bold, chef-crafted flavors, fresh ingredients, and over 40 grams of protein, they're built to satisfy without slowing you down.
或者您获取播客的任何地方收听《心理学热线》的往期节目。如果您喜欢我们的节目，请给我们留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发电子邮件至 SpeakingofPsychology@apa.org。《心理学热线》由莉·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·孔迪（Chris Kondy）。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学协会的金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。Sweetgreen推出了全新的用餐方式。肉类卷饼、便携手卷、丰盛美味，专为忙碌生活打造。凭借大胆的主厨手艺风味、新鲜食材和超过40克的蛋白质，它们旨在满足您的味蕾却不会拖慢您的脚步。
Try wraps today in the app or at order.sweetgreen.com, available at all participating locations. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
今天就在应用程序或 order.sweetgreen.com 上尝试卷饼吧，所有参与活动的门店均有售。本集节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。